[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravi de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro du skyco le
magazine qui vous raconte les aventures
économiques du territoire de
Saint-Quentin en Yvelines et dans cette
édition nous allons plonger dans le
monde de l'économie sociale et solidaire
et pour cela nous sommes sur le site
d'envie à Trappes cette association
d'insertion professionnelle et
spécialisée dans la collecte la
réparation et la vente de produits
électroménagers reconditionné nous
allons rencontrer le directeur de ce
site et aussi un collaborateur il s'agit
de Philippe Lenaerts 63 ans mais en
attendant voici le programme de ce 50e
numéro du skyco le mois de novembre a
été consacré à l'économie sociale et
solidaire un secteur en pleine expansion
à travers ses acteurs notamment sur le
territoire de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
la trappe depuis 2012 l'association
envie est engagée dans l'insertion
professionnelle et la lutte contre le
gaspillage nous ferons le bilan de ces
10 années d'existence enfin découverte
de la start-up haïtijah incubé au ski
cube elle développe une application
destinée au lycéen pour les aider dans
leur orientation une rencontre des
acteurs de le SS le 30 novembre dernier
Saint-Quentin en Yvelines a organisé un
après-midi consacré à l'économie sociale
et solidaire au ski cube un événement
pour conclure le mois consacré à cette
thématique et c'était l'occasion pour
l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines de sortir se
fascicule qui répertorie l'ensemble des
acteurs de l'économie sociale et
solidaire du territoire alors qu'est-ce
qui se cache derrière ce terme ESS
regardez ce décryptage
[Musique]
c'est l'insertion
pour moi un mot ce serait les liens le
SS en un mot c'est
partage
[Musique]
ESF l'économie sociale et solidaire
c'est une autre façon de faire
l'économie elle repose sur la loi de
2014 et elle regroupe les associations
les fondations les mutuelles les
coopératives et les entreprises qui ont
fait le choix d'être labellisé
ezus
[Musique]
elle repose aussi sur trois grands
principes une gouvernance intégrante
l'ensemble des parties prenantes un
autre but recherché que le simple
partage des bénéfices et la non
lucrativité ou lucrativité limitée
[Musique]
les activités de la vie quotidienne par
exemple l'emploi l'insertion le sport la
culture les loisirs mais aussi
l'économie circulaire l'environnement
[Musique]
notre activité s'inscrit pleinement dans
le SS puisqu'on accompagne 8 ouvriers en
parcours d'insertion qui sont chez nous
sur une durée jusqu'à 24 mois maximum
dans un poste d'ouvrier paysagiste et
l'idée c'est qu'à traverser
professionnel pour pouvoir ensuite
intégrer une entreprise dite classique
et ordinaire du monde du paysage mais le
jeu s'inscrit Clément le SS parce que
c'est une mutuelle et répond à un besoin
de complémentaires santé puisque la
psychothée sociale rembourse une partie
de des soins mais la mutuelle rembourse
l'autre partie la copie la roise
s'inscrit dans l'économie sociale du
fait que ce soit une coopérative sous
statut SCOP c'est à dire que c'est une
coopérative de travailleurs avec des
travailleurs et des travailleurs qui
font démocratie ensemble dans le travail
de magasins bio coopératif est soutenu
par une association de clients et de
bénévoles financièrement par des apports
dans la poursuite de l'activité
économique
[Musique]
il favorise l'insertion professionnelle
et la lutte contre le gaspillage le
réseau en vie est spécialisé dans la
réparation de produits d'électroménagers
par des personnes éloignées de l'emploi
le site de trap a été créé en 2012 et
pour en parler nous sommes avec Eric
Gatineau bonjour bonjour
alors vous avez soufflé votre dixième
bougie cette année quel bilan vous
faites de ces 10 ans d'existence ça fait
10 ans très très riche c'était une
aventure depuis 10 ans avec aujourd'hui
la grande satisfaction de pouvoir dire
qu'on a remis un peu plus de 200
personnes sur le chemin de l'emploi et
puis sur le plan économique on a
également et environnemental on a
développé en disant notre action pour
sauver des appareils des déchets pour
les remettre sur le marché les rénover
aujourd'hui on voit à peu près 5000
appareils par an quand on a commencé on
était plutôt autour de 1500 2000
appareils par an le but de l'économie
sociale et solidaire ce n'est pas le
profit en tout cas c'est pas la priorité
de faire de la rentabilité néanmoins il
en faut un minimum sur quel modèle
économique repose l'association en vie
vous avez raison c'est une association
donc à une association à but non
lucratif néanmoins pour pouvoir se
développer
va pouvoir investir pour pouvoir
recruter pour pouvoir recruter à la fois
des personnels qui sont éloignés de
l'emploi et les remettre sur le chemin
de l'emploi donc les former et avoir un
accompagnement de qualité et puis pour
avoir des encadrants de haut niveau sur
des recrutements structurants mais il
faut gagner de l'argent il faut il faut
pouvoir pouvoir
dégager des ressources dans notre modèle
l'intégralité de la richesse dégagée par
les ventes de nos produits et
réintroduites dans l'association il n'y
a pas de distribution de richesse à
l'extérieur donc ça nous permet
d'avancer nous développer comme ça alors
c'est un budget de combien annuel en
moyenne sur 2022 on sera sur un budget
d'un million 8
avec
un million 500
000 euros de ressources dégagées par les
ventes de produits et de services
associés et puis on a environ 300 000
euros de subventions pour l'aide au
poste en fait on reçoit de la part de
l'État un accompagnement c'est un
forfait de 11000 par an par équivalent
en plein pour l'insertion et reste à
charge pour nous d'environ 13000 euros
par poste alors l'appétence vis-à-vis
des produits de seconde vie c'est aussi
booster par les évolutions législatives
je suppose que l'urgence climatique
aussi la conscience autour du de cette
urgence climatique et les évolutions
législatives tout cela favorise votre
activité exactement c'est ce sont les
deux en fait et là rejoint l'autre ou
accélérer par l'autre il y a une prise
de conscience de plus en plus forte du
grand public sur la nécessité de lutter
contre le gaspillage et d'économiser de
la ressource c'est lié à l'urgence
climatique et aux dérèglement climatique
et le lien que l'on fait avec notre
économie mondialisée et ces changements
climatiques là donc nous on propose un
modèle très local de production locale
de circuits très courts qui intéresse de
plus en plus de monde
et puis la loi
législatif accompagné cette évolution là
il a encouragé avec notamment la loi
anti-gaspillage pour l’économie
circulaire qui a
pour pour but d'accélérer le processus
et qui ouvre à la fois des opportunités
pour des structures comme la nôtre
et puis on peut le dire aussi des
nouvelles interrogations ou des
nouvelles menaces parce qu'on rentre
dans un marché aujourd'hui très
fortement concurrentiel il y a une
quarantaine de collaborateurs qui font
le quotidien d'envie du site envie de
trappes et puis justement on va aller
rejoindre l'un d'entre eux c'est
Philippe Le nertz qui est opérateur de
production merci
Eric Gatineau merci à vous
[Musique]
et il travaille depuis 5 ans et demi
dans le réseau en vie sur le site de
trap nous sommes avec Philippe bonjour
bonjour
alors vous êtes actuellement en train de
réparer ce four qu'est-ce qui se passe
donc je reçois une fiche
donc notifiant donc le problème de la de
la pâte donc c'est à moi à chercher à
trouver la panne de cet appareil de ce
trou et donc ça c'est quelque chose que
vous faites au quotidien c'est ça voilà
c'est ça plus souvent de la rénovation
c'est à dire qu'on reçoit de d'artiste
si vous voulez des
appareils qui sont jetés à la poubelle
d'accord qu'on répare et qu'on nettoie
complètement donc on refait à neuf et
vous êtes spécialisés sur un type
d'appareil en particulier parce qu'on a
vu il y a des machines à laver il y a
des lave-vaisselle tout ce qui est
cuisson donc au four cuisinière plaque
induction et voilà alors pourquoi vous
avez rejoint le site envie à trappe il y
a 5 ans et demi
je travaillais à Lille où j'ai eu en
bureaux donc j'ai tout laissé tomber à
Lille et donc je me suis un peu baladé
comme ça sans
en faisant un peu en allant un peu
partout en France et comme j'ai une sœur
qui est ici à Montigny donc c'est plutôt
ma famille qui m'a demandé de stabiliser
pas oublier que à l'époque j'avais 57
ans donc je me posais des questions à
savoir
quel âge de venir puisque je suis arrivé
ici sans rien donc et le fait donc de
trouver du travail à envie il y a 57 ans
m'a donné la possibilité de reprendre
de reprendre mon avis en main jusqu'à 57
ans vous ne savez pas où c'est perdu
vous savez pas quoi vous dites bon
quelques vais-je devenir quoi
et donc là ça m'a permis voilà de
d'avoir du travail de retrouver un
logement enfin tout est a suivi c'est un
cheminement voilà grâce à envie qu'il
m'a permis voilà maintenant j'ai mon
appartement j'ai
un salaire je suis bien dans ma peau
puis voilà quoi bien justement quel sens
vous donnez à votre activité
professionnelle pourquoi vous vous êtes
motivé à vous lever chaque matin
parce que d'abord je
j'aime ce travail et c'est vrai que
j'aide beaucoup ici de par mon
expérience donc c'est le fait à des
jeunes il y a beaucoup il y a pas mal de
jeunes qui sont là et je leur apprends
avec mon âge maintenant j'ai 63 ans je
veux dire que j'ai appelé plus de 40 ans
que je travaille donc j'ai un certain
savoir et le fait de partager ce savoir
ben voilà ça ça me ça me donne comment
dirais-je une
allez c'est tendre la main aussi vous à
votre tour parce que envie vous attendu
la main et vous c'est aujourd'hui vous
tendez la main aux jeunes et aux autres
collaborateurs qui vous entourent au
quotidien c'est ça je leur dois
pratiquement entre guillemets
ou ma vie puisque à 57 ans quand vous
avez plus rien vous êtes perdu vous vous
posez énormément de questions et puis
que vais-je faire qui suis-je voilà et
donc là ça vous remet sur sur le monde
du travail et en plus vous aider des
jeunes et donc là c'est à votre tour
d'aider de partager surtout que ces
gens-là ont besoin
parce que c'est de l'insertion donc ce
sont des gens peut-être qui n'ont jamais
terminé leurs études et qui des fois
arrivent à 25 ans sans
rien donc bah il faut leur montrer voilà
ce qu'est le travail être là avec mon
air fixe et puis respecter le et puis ce
mec comme comme pour moi une rampe de
lancement et à 25 ans que si vous n'avez
pas de travail
il y a rien qui suit quoi je veux dire
ils sont encore chez leurs parents en
plus merci beaucoup Philippe
opérateur de production sur le site
envie de trap merci
je m'appelle Sonia j'ai 38 ans et j'ai
créé et une start-up dédiée à
l'orientation des jeunes
âgés de 14 à 18 ans
aujourd'hui donc on est deux moi et mon
consommateur la startup on a lancé début
2021 ça a commencé aussi avec beaucoup
de travail de prospection j'ai moi-même
interviewé pratiquement 200 personnes
pour comprendre leurs besoins
le but d'étuja c'est de donner la bonne
information à la bonne personne au bon
moment et donc d'orienter les jeunes
dans leur choix de formation et de
métier plus tard
quand vous entrez sur notre plateforme
vous commencez par un test à un test qui
est assez court qui nous permet nous de
déterminer un profil et à partir de ce
profil-là on va vous proposer des
secteurs et des métiers qui peuvent vous
intéresser l'idée c'est que vous ayez
accès à la totalité notre base de
données en termes de métier et de
secteur on l'organise simplement en
fonction de vos préférences en fonction
aussi de vos caractéristiques c'est à
dire votre âge là où vous habitez
l'établissement dans lequel vous êtes on
va vous proposer en fait les meilleures
établissements les meilleurs filières
qui correspondent à vos aspirations
il y a deux éléments qui sont très
importants dans l'outil qu'on a
développé il y a ce qu'on appelle
l'interface donc ce que voit
l'utilisateur sur lequel on a énormément
travaillé pour que la présentation de
l'information soit la plus claire et la
plus limpide possible derrière en fait
il y a énormément de travail autour de
la data notamment autour de ce qu'on
appelle l'Open Data au niveau français
donc toutes les données qui sont
disponibles sur les établissements sur
les spécialités mais également sur les
métiers qu'on travaille aussi avec des
bases de données européennes en termes
de métier et de compétences
on est en train de travailler avec nos
partenaires pour développer la
plateforme l'objectif c'est qu'elle soit
prête pour la rentrée prochaine donc
septembre 2023 pour pouvoir l'utiliser
avec les premiers les premiers
utilisateurs c'est la fin de ce numéro
merci de l'avoir suivi vous pouvez
revoir cette émission en replay sur
notre site Internet ou sur l'application
mobile à bientôt sur TV 78
[Musique]